herzlich willkommen zur heute show am
ende einer sommerlichen woche und so
schön schönes wetter ist es schlägt
leider auf die wahlbeteiligung
historisch miese 55 prozent bei der
kleinen bundestagswahl in nordrhein
westfalen da sind wohl einige lieber am
baggersee geblieben als ihrer
vornehmsten bürger pflicht nachzukommen
wie kann das sein traurig wirklich
traurig wahrscheinlich müssen wir alle
wahlen auf ende november legen damit das
besser klappt aber kommt es gab ja auch
gute nachrichten in nrw hat die afc ihr
nächstes wahlen grad erlebt meine damen
und herren
nur noch 5,4 prozent schon die zehnte
mal in folge mit verlusten für die
alternative kino copala hier gerät
zunehmend unter druck weist aber jede
kritik weit von sich mit einem besonders
blumigen vergleich das ist wie früher
beim camping ich vergleiche das immer so
haben sie immer diejenigen beschwert das
ist nass im zelt sind ist und das waren
diejenigen die auch ein zelt hinein
gepinkelt haben und das muss aufhören
das muss aufhören was macht der denn für
campingurlauber ich wusste ja das thema
ddr immer alle nackt waren aber die
pinke leid na ja so was macht die wahl
von düsseldorf mit der ampel in berlin
hauptsächlich schlechte laune zwei
parteien gerupft nur eine happy die
selbsternannte fortschritts koalition
ist plötzlich ein fall für die
paartherapie scholz und lindner fragen
sich von morgens bis abends was haben
die grünen was sie nicht haben die fdp
hat hier in nordrhein westfalen mal eben
mehr als halbiert hier christian lindner
mit trauma bewältigung durch poesie
gestern war ein trauriger abend
heute ist ein neuer tag
tränen sind getrocknet
die tränen sind getrocknet die wiese ist
gemäht die messe ist gelesen
der drops ist gelutscht hinten kackt die
ente ihr christian lendner
ein projekt
gerade mal 5,9 prozent für die fdp oder
um es mal liberal auszudrücken der markt
hat es geregelt
gut zum teil lag natürlich an
landesthemen schulpolitik aber sicher
auch an der rolle der liberalen in der
ampel einfach nur projekte von anderen
verhindern stichwort tempolimit reicht
halt nicht auf die dauer wofür steht die
partei klar christian lindner hier denkt
sich ständig neue worte für schulden aus
aber sonst andererseits wollte er ja
unbedingt finanzminister werden wissen
sie noch war das eigentlich eine schlaue
idee
nein
glaube ich auch nicht
ampel kassen war das wünscht man im
moment keinem vor allem jetzt wo die
stagnation vor der tür steht also
stagnation plus inflation womit wir auch
schon bei den grundrechenarten wären
fast alle relevanten ökonomen übrigens
auch konservative sagen deutschland kann
im nächsten jahr die schuldenbremse
natürlich nicht einhalten also
jedenfalls nicht ohne steuererhöhungen
wieso hält lindner trotzdem eisern an
beiden fest ist ja fast schon tragisch
wir verzichten auf steuererhöhungen
sondern arbeiten an steuerlichen
entlastungen zum zweiten kehren wir im
nächsten jahr zur schuldenbremse des
grundgesetzes
zurück
jeder zweite fdp finanzminister mit nrw
abitur leidet untere dyskalkulie
schreibe ich nicht ab lernen richtig
rechnen eins und eins ist eins und nicht
1 und 11 ich kenne gesamtschulen da gibt
es dafür noch eine drei plus meine damen
und herren
so die fdp erreicht gerade so den ganz
harten kern ihrer stammwähler in nrw die
grünen dagegen dringen erfolgreich vor
in neue milieus wie machen die das gute
frage sie kommunizieren sie
kommunizieren besser und ganz wichtig
sie haben sich die richtigen ressorts im
bund rausgefischt robert habeck zb kann
als wirtschaftsminister der belegschaft
der öl raffinerie in schwedt hilfe
versprechen aber die rechnung nicht wer
anders die bundesregierung würde
einsteigen und dafür sorge tragen also
würde dann in den indie in die
finanziellen risiken reingehen christian
lindner bezahlt sozusagen
in dem indie kurz gesagt das geht alles
auf den deckel von linda ich bin
bergleute
ja kein wunder dass sich die grünen in
nordrhein-westfalen verdreifacht haben
und sie werden wohl in düsseldorf
mitregieren zusammen mit der cdu der
neuen deutschen party partei
druckbetankung go es wird ordentlich
bier und wein getrunken 500 liter bier
hat die cdu hier geordert und die
biervorräte wenn wir uns mal so wissen
umgucken auch das was schon getrunken
wird hier fließt schon das gegen endlich
in georgien hieß es dass er mit den
schnäpsen heute abend oder abträglich
bild weil ich war früher schon um 6 uhr
flieger airbus aus berlin
aber jetzt zurück ins köln
zurück ins köln warum nicht auch nicht
ins düsseldorf wiederum bleibt jetzt
ministerpräsident hendrik wüst im amt
wie es aussieht und das verdankt er
nicht zuletzt seinem überragenden erfolg
vor allem bei den älteren menschen ja
ist der tatsache ist eine tatsache
43 prozent der über 60 jährigen haben
ihr kreuz bei der cdu gemacht wieder
einmal erweist sich also dass die best
age die eigentliche macht im land sind
und unter den älteren sind es wiederum
die chicks die beim wüst ganz wuschig
werden die älteren passantinnen sind
begeistert
[Musik]
ist das wäre auch kein schlechtes plakat
hendrik wüst nicht so lässig wie manche
so rumlaufen
was für ein genialer schachzug seiner
leute die marketing strategen von
anderen parteien konzentrieren sich auf
junge urbane hipster süß kampagne ziel
stattdessen clevere weise direkt ins
doppelherz
ach der herr wüst so ein gepflegter
junger mann tadellose manieren guck mal
der grüßt noch haare immer ganz akkurat
als chef muss er den angestellten alles
erklären kein wunder
zwei davon sind frauen
hendrik wüst du willst doch auch ein
enkelkind von ihm
diese gebe es
für dich auch nimmt übrigens
ausdrücklich kein vorwurf an die alten
die gehen wenigstens so war egal wie das
wetter ist nrw wird also wohl schwarz
grün regiert und die spd holt ihr
schlechtestes ergebnis seit 1947
eine frage so was hat immer viele
ursachen aber es hat möglicherweise auch
mit olaf scholz zu tun beziehungsweise
mit seinem kommunikationstalent der oft
etwas kryptischen ausdrucksweise ist
eine these
eine these von vielen meine dabei waren
die sozen doch letzten sonntag in
düsseldorf so zuversichtlich also bis
kurz vor 18 uhr und die spd hat auch
großes vor und diese zuversicht spiegelt
sich auch in der weinauswahl wieder der
grauburgunder heißt punktlandung und der
rosé wunderschön
mussten sie leider alles komplett weg
kippen
stattdessen gab es den riesling
bauchlandung
und den weizenkorn filmriss für
wahlabend zum vergessen
wenigstens der hatte 40 ja es ist ja wir
lachen aber es ist natürlich alles
ziemlich bitter wir scheint mal live in
die spd wahlkampfzentrale im willy
brandt haus wo dieser flagge die neu
gegründete arbeitsgruppe wer ist schuld
leitet frau flagge wer ist schuld auch
der kanzler
schwer zu sagen
wir haben ganz nrw zugekleistert mit
plakaten vormonat er ist von brilon bis
gipfel rufen in jedem cook ab
aufgetreten und dann haben wir 800
tausend sender verloren gibt ein
zusammenhang da müsste ich jetzt warten
okay wie wollen sie denn olaf scholz
wieder populärer machen oder ich sage
mal seine kommunikation verbessern sorry
aber da geht mir schon die frage thema
auf den sack aber der robert habeck
edith mit dem bürger auf augenhöhe
doch alle ich hätte auch wenn robert
habeck aber ich habe ein olaf scholz
einen mann der sich zur lebensaufgabe
macht alles immer so um konkret wie
irgend möglich zu sagen ich habe ja
schon eine studie laufen um
herauszufinden was mit testpersonen
macht wenn die ganze schuld regen am
stück hören er hier kommt er für zehn
minuten
jetzt schon keine messbaren tätigkeit
mehr
das ist so notfallmechanismus der
frontallappen schafft es ein bestimmtes
maß an langeweile zu ertragen dann fährt
er unter
leute bringen man frischen rein der
jetzt durch so das kommt halt von diesen
schuldigen nullinger setzen der chef
trommelt die weltpresse zusammen und
haut dann ernsthaft sätze raus wie ich
bin
sehr sicher dass es gelungen ist die
wichtigen fragen zu besprechen
oh
gott sie haben ja ein trinkspiel jedes
mal wenn olaf sagt wir werden das
notwendige tun oder im einklang mit
unseren partnern müssen wir in schnaps
trinken nach drei tagen waren alle
hardcore alkoholiker okay okay meine
rhetorik ist das ein aber entscheidende
frage ist doch konkrete politik genau da
läuft ja super ich sage eine reise nach
kiew
da arbeitet er inzwischen schon mit der
dritten ausrede zuletzt hieß es die
ukraine müssten erstmal steinmeier
empfangen und jetzt sagt er plötzlich
ich werde nicht mich ein rein in eine
gruppe von leuten die für ein kurzes ein
und raus mit einem fototermin was machen
sie denn dann geht es immer um ganz
konkrete dinge
kurzes rein raus mit fototermin sie bei
mir zu hause
und was gibt es in kiel schon konkret zu
besprechen also außer dem krieg jetzt
oder dass wir deutschen immer schwere
waffen versprechen die aber nie kommen
und wenn dann ohne munition und wir
wundern uns in einer weniger geht's gut
da hat sich ja bei ihnen allerhand
aufgestaut gefährdet das jetzt die
harmonie in der ampel so dass nur die
grünen ab sagt nein quatsch nein wir
arbeiten weiter konstruktiv zusammen ich
lasse mich jetzt sogar von grünen pr
leuten beraten alisa alles gut bei dir
ich hab dir ein schatten
dieser flagge
[Applaus]
ich wollte euch nur um ein kleines auto
bieten einfach anklicken
märz gut
los
los du scheiße fährt